brainwashing betrayal boughs and ballads
the story of The Hunger Games begins way
before Katniss and even before snow
here's the whole timeline spoilers ahead
for the entire Hunger Games franchise
the nation of panm doesn't just appear
overnight it forms in the ruins of our
civilization the world changes forever
with the onset of climate change natural
disasters like fires droughts and storms
cause the planet's resources to dwindle
countries begin to fight over the
remaining resources causing War to break
out across the globe with such
widespread Bloodshed governments around
the world begin to collapse and the
human population rapidly decreases
nearly creating an extinction level
event From the Ashes of society in North
America Rises panm a new nation with a
capital based in the Rocky Mountains
history is a little murky around this
period it isn't clear exactly when panm
forms after the fall of other
pre-existing civilizations or when panm
divides into districts you're not off to
a real good start what we do know is
that each district provides the capital
with a vital resource though the
districts are reliant on the capital to
ensure the distribution of those
resources the capital exploits the
districts it rules over by controlling
its exclusive access to necessities and
this eventually causes the districts to
turn on the capital the idea for The
Hunger Games comes long before the
Rebellion that causes its implementation
Cris snow future president Cory Elena
Snow's father attends the capitals
University with his best friend Casa
High bottom the dean of the academy cor
alanus attends years later the two are
in a class taught by Dr volumnia Gul a
scientist who later becomes the first
head games maker while Gul and cr's snow
get along well Gul and high bottom do
not for their final project Gul tasks
the students with developing a
hypothetical punishment that would
ensure their enemies never forgot what
they did to them snow works with high
bottom and gets him drunk while hearing
what he has to say about the assignment
snow turns his idea in as their
assignment the two fight over this High
Bottom never forgives snow and
eventually takes out that frustration on
Snow's son even though it's originally
meant as a class assignment Gul uses the
proposal to create an annual punishment
for the districts after the rebellion
and high bottom goes down in history as
the brains behind the games at an
unknown point after the founding of
PanAm the districts begin to grow
restless with the power dynamics at play
this part of history is documented
mostly by the capital and since they're
pretty good at propaganda it's hard to
say how much is true Capital children
learned that rebels in District 13 were
the instigators behind the first
rebellion and used its privilege as a
nuclear research facility to its
Advantage this was the uprising that
rocked our land War spreads throughout
PM with other District rising up and
holding their resources hostage from the
capital the unrest continues to grow
over the course of around 3 years
turning into Air Raids on the country's
political Center the ruling class of
panm spends most of the war under the
grip of the districts because of its
Reliance on them for goods and services
the elite often find themselves without
power or Essentials as different
districts join the cause when the
districts invade the capital the
direction of the war turns despite being
the alleged starting point of the
Rebellion District 13 begins to pull
back and eventually Brokers a deal with
the capital the conflict ends with the
secret agreement that District 13 will
be allowed to live on just not as a
member of panm the other 12 districts
watches the capital bombs and destroys
the surface of District 13 which leads
them to believe the district is Gone
without 13's support the rest of the
districts can no longer maintain their
War efforts falling to the capital as
the military sweeps through the country
as as the capital regains control they
develop the Treaty of treason the treaty
creates a variety of restrictions for
the citizens of panm including Banning
communication and travel between
districts it also leads to the
implementation of their punishment The
Hunger Games is the most significant
part of the treaty the annual event that
forces the districts to sacrifice two
children every year in a televised
battle to the death since the dark days
our great nation has known only peace
the first rebellion and dark days also
Mark a turning point in corilanus Snow's
life just 5 years old when the war
begins the young snow watches on as the
civilization he grows up with almost
falls to the districts Snow's mother
dies in childbirth and shortly after his
father who has risen through the
military ranks dies in Rebel fire with
his cousin tigress's parents also dead
the two of them live with their
grandmother the snow name affords the
future president of panm many privileges
early on but that all goes away with
District 13 most of the family's assets
are nuclear research so when District 13
is bombed the family's riches and Status
plummet even as snow becomes an adult
his home is still significantly damaged
from the first Rebellion because his
family can't afford the repairs the
first nine Hunger Games are drastically
different from what the event eventually
becomes by oh the 74th one when it is
time for the games to begin all 24
tributes in enter the capital arena with
few weapons and no food and are left to
fight to the death once crowned the
winner the victor goes home returning to
their life as it was before they
competed in the Hunger Games the early
games were particularly barbaric even
compared to later evolutions of the
event this is the price of Peace the
only thing that remains unchanged from
the early games is the selection of
tributes from the beginning the tributes
from each district are chosen through a
lottery system selecting one female and
one male child between the ages of 12
and 18 the 10th Hunger Games is when the
event changes to create a more watchable
experience to do this several key
elements that later become Staples in
the games are introduced including
mentors the ability to give gifts to
tributes once they are in the arena and
tribute interviews the first mentors are
Academy students who are just Capital
teens trying to finish their High School
level education before heading off to
University to help introduce these new
elements several changes take place in
how the games function rather than the
games starting soon after all the
tributes arrive in the capital the
contestants are instead placed in an old
animal enclosure in the capital Zoo
essentially on display for Capital
citizens to come and see over several
days they tour the arena meet with their
mentors and participate in interviews on
Capital television starting with the
10th games the event moves in a more
spectacle like Direction Your Role is to
turn these children into spectacles not
survivors Cory Elena snow is one of the
first mentors overseeing and Advising
Lucy Gray beard the musically gifted
female tribute from District 12 during
the 10th Hunger Games this begins his
close connection with The Hunger Games
moving from mentor to a games maker
Apprentice while attending University
the young snow connects with his tribute
Lucy gray and uses tricks to ensure she
becomes the Victor making him the first
mentor to coach a winning tribute while
working as a mentor he writes the
proposal for the implementation of a
bedding and odd system and the ability
to send food to tributes in the arena
two ways Capital citizens can
participate and create an emotional
attachment to the games he also gets to
see and learn about one of the mutations
Dr Gull snakes before she drops them in
the arena After High bottom discovers
that snow used that info to cheat to
help Lucy gray win snow becomes a
peacekeeper but before long he heads
back to the capital and starts an
apprentice ship under Dr Gaul to be a
games maker during this time he
continues introducing New Concepts for
the games after winning the 10th Hunger
Games and returning to her life in
district 12 Lucy gray Bayard continues
to play music the atmosphere in district
12 is less than ideal to put it lightly
people are really struggling with the
newly reinforced regime of the capital
and as Lucy gray watches these events
play out in her home she takes to her
guitar to express her thoughts on the
subject she writes the Hanging Tree
about the death of Arlo chance a minor
and supporter of the Rebellion it is one
of many songs she writes but this one
has the most impact after her
disappearance and presumed death despite
the Banning of music the song survives
for generations with Katniss's father
teaching it to her before his death
while considered an act of rebellion by
peacekeepers when it is written the song
becomes synonymous with the second
Rebellion when Katniss sings it during a
rebellion filmed TV spot in the Hunger
Game mocking J part
one a little on the nose but of course
so is war when it comes time to select
tributes for the 74th Annual Hunger
Games everything proceedes as usual
until Primrose everine is drawn as the
female tribute for District 12 Prim is
only 12 years old meaning this is her
first year of eligibility for the games
and has already had to endure the loss
of her father in a mining accident years
prior unwilling to allow Prim to be
selected for almost certain death for
older sister Katniss everine volunteers
to compete in her place Peta the son of
a local Baker is chosen as the male
tribute from District 12 although both
Katniss and Peta know only one of them
will make it out of the Arena they grow
fond of one another in the days leading
up to the games during their training
Katniss establishes herself as an
accomplished Archer while Peta impresses
his fellow tributes with his natural
strength and his uncanny ability to
paint tree bark meanwhile back in
district 12 Katniss's best friend Gail
Hawthorne looks after Katniss's mother
and sister as they all watch the TV
coverage all these people may seem like
normal citizens but they turn out to be
pretty important in the years to come as
the 74th Hunger Games begin Katniss
Ventures out on her own she becomes
convinced that Peta is working with
other tributes to kill her even though
he's actually trying to protect her by
throwing them off her scent eventually
Katniss teams up with Rue the
12-year-old tribute from District 11 and
things start looking up
we're going to be
okay Unfortunately they aren't okay Rue
is killed and Katniss Mourns her by
covering her body with flowers an action
that galvanizes District 11 following
ru's death a changed the rules as
announced two Victors may be crowned
this year provided they're from the same
district Peta and Katniss promptly team
up to defeat the other tributes this
strategy wins the hearts of capital
sponsors who enjoy what they Perce
perceive as a blooming romance between
the two thanks to the timely supplies
they send some very quick thinking and a
fair amount of luck Katniss and pea
become the final two tributes standing
but then the announcer reveals that the
previous Ru change has been undone only
one of them will be allowed to leave the
arena alive neither Katniss nor pea is
willing to kill the other so they
resolve to kill themselves by eating
poisonous berries panicked at the
thought of not having a Victor at all
the announcer changes the rules yet
again to allow for two Victors ending
the games head game maker cynica crane
is subsequently executed by President
Cory Elena snow for this decision The
Hunger Games Catching Fire opens as the
citizens of panm prepare for the 75th
Hunger Games in the leadup to each games
it's customary for the winner of the
prior blood bath to go on a victory tour
of the 12 districts to drum up
enthusiasm as well as demonstrate
loyalty to the capital but Katniss and
peta's Defiance in the 74 Hunger Games
has stirred unrest ahead of the 75th
games the people of panm see Katniss as
a symbol of resistance and the capital
isn't pleased before Katniss and Peta
leave on their tour President Snow tells
Katniss she needs to convince the public
that her attempt to subvert the rules by
eating the berries was motivated solely
by love for PETA or he will kill her
family it must be a fragile system if it
can be brought down by just a few
berries yes it is indeed but not in the
way you imagine it Katniss and Peta do
their best to present themselves as a
legitimate couple during their tour but
it's not enough to quench the anger of
the districts which is spreading like
wildfire it doesn't help that Katniss
isn't a very convincing actress and also
prone to acting impulsively she
intervenes in several instances of
capital sanctioned brutality this only
strengthens The public's perception of
her as the mocking jay a potent symbol
of freedom and Rebellion the 75th Hunger
Games are much different than the ritual
the year before they're the third
quarter quell a special game that takes
place every 25 years still seeking to
smother the people's anger snow along
with newly appointed head game maker
Plutarch hensby decides that the
tributes will be selected from the
existing pool of Victors since Katniss
is the only living female Victor from
District 12 there is no question that
she will be among those forced to return
to the arena of District 12's two male
Victor
hch abery Victor of the 50th games and
Katniss and peta's Mentor is selected to
compete to Katniss's horror Peta
volunteers to take his place once
they've arrived at the capital the mood
of the 75th Hunger Games tributes is
revealed to be markedly different than
that of previous years already having
survived one round of brutality this
group is rightfully angry that instead
of being allowed to live out their lives
in peace and comfort they are instead
being sent back into the arena as
they're older and considerably more
experienced than the children typically
selected for the games these tributes
boldly try a number of tactics to get
the game shut down unbeknownst to
catniss secret resistance Ally plutar
Heavens meets with hitch as well as a
number of other tributes to conspire
about what will happen if the games
proceed under instructions from
president Al mcoin leader of District 13
which not only exists but is actively
plotting a rebellion Heavens be hitch
and several tributes including Finnick
and Joanna devise a plan to extract
Katniss and Pea from the games once
they're underway the 75th Hunger Games
circular Arena has a large lake in the
center and is divided into 12 wedges
this time Katniss and Peta immediately
team up and are quickly joined by
Finnick and elderly mags although mags
soon sacrifices herself to save the
others the rest survive and are joined
by Joanna along with wirus and Bey from
District 3 an accomplished engineer Bey
devices a plan to use one of the Arena's
precisely timed traps to their advantage
using a spool of copper wire he intends
to harness the electricity from a
lightning strike to electrocute the
other
tributes how do we know the wire is not
going to burn up because I invented it
presumably his intent following the
elimination of the other tributes is to
trigger District 13's rescue plan though
of course Katniss and pea know nothing
about this when the plan goes arry at
the last second Katniss wraps the end of
the copper wire around an arrow and
shoots it at the force field ceiling of
the Arena right as Lightning Strikes the
current is drawn into the Dome causing
it to short out and subsequently crumble
this allows a large District 13 ship to
enter and extract Katniss and several
other tributes unfortunately Peta and
Joanna are left behind and sent to the
capital while Katniss is taken to
District 13 unable to be rescued by
District 13
Peta and Joanna are interrogated and
tortured by the capital Peta doesn't
know anything about the resistance but
snow rightly assumes he can use him as
leverage to influence Katniss through a
number of televised propaganda spots
filmed in the capital Katniss sees Peta
become ever more alarmingly brainwashed
during this time another former winner
Annie Cresta and Joanna are also
tortured by the capital although they
are not shown on television as pea is
but the capital's actions are even worse
than they think when he isn't filming
propaganda spots Peta is being subjected
to vicious brainwashing techniques which
cause him to become fearful of Katniss
although she would like nothing more
than to go charging into the capital to
rescue Peta Katniss is now subject to
the administration of president coin who
is determined to work more strategically
as The Hunger Games Mocking J part 1
opens coin convinces Katniss to embrace
her Persona as the mocking jay and film
a series of propaganda videos to Inspire
the people of panm with District 12
reduced to smoking rubble and Katniss's
mother Prim and Gail now residing in
District 13 Katniss feels she has no
choice people of PM we fight we dare to
end this hunger for
justice unfortunately for coin Katniss
is no more convincing when delivering
scripted monologues for a cause she
believes in than one she doesn't however
she is occasionally inspired to
improvise and manages is to give a few
impassioned speeches that successfully
rally the districts once again snow
doesn't like what Katniss is up to and
he finally orders an Airborne attack on
District 13 Peta is able to regain
control of himself just long enough to
warn Katniss and the other residents of
the district to take shelter resulting
in far fewer casualties than there
otherwise would have been finally
president coin authorizes a mission to
rescue Peta and the other Victors from
the capital though Katniss is not
allowed to to join the rescue team
instead she is tasked with filming a
live broadcast to snow in the hopes of
distracting him from seeing what's
happening right under his nose until he
reveals that he knows exactly what's
happening yet somehow Peta Joanna and
Annie are successfully rescued Gail who
participated in the rescue mission
observes that finding and retrieving
them was almost too easy every gun was
back online and H us and we flew right
past them they let us go the reason
reason for this is made clear when
Katniss eagerly rushes to reunite with
Peta only to have him viciously attack
her at this point it becomes clear to
the resistance that snow has brainwashed
Peta into wanting to kill Katniss then
allowed him to be rescued while the
resistance's doctors work diligently to
counteract peta's brainwashing Katniss
is told she will have to keep her
distance for the safety of them both as
the hunger game's mocking jay part two
begins Katniss is determined to seek
revenge for peta's condition following a
series of successful attacks by Rebel
forces the capital troops withdraw from
the districts to regroup within the
capital itself they place a number of
lethal traps called pods around the
outskirts of the city to prevent
resistance fighters from advancing
fortunately the resistance is able to
procure a device which allows them to
see the placement of most but not all of
these pods increasing their chances of
being able to successfully reach the
capital Center where President Snow
resides Katniss and Gail are placed on a
team dubbed the the star Squad which is
meant to follow the combat troops and
film propaganda videos showcasing the
resistance's successes they've barely
made it into the city when Peta is added
to the group under coin's orders
allegedly to show the capital that he is
still loyal to the resistance however
the team suspects he's there to kill
Katniss since her high-profile status as
the mocking jay poses a threat to coin's
power she never liked you she doesn't
like anybody or anything she can't
control so she would put my life in
danger but despite their misgivings the
group pushes deeper into the city
unfortunately between the pods and
peta's violent programming this Mission
proves deadly for most of the team
including finck only Katniss Gail Peta
and a couple members of the camera crew
make it to the center of the capital
alive realizing that the capital is
losing the War President Snow invites
the remaining Capital citizens to gather
around his mansion and bring the
children toward the gates in the hopes
that a human shield will dissuade the
rebels from fighting their way inside
but as Katniss and Gail work their way
toward the mansion disguised as
civilians fighting breaks out they're
separated when Gail is arrested by
Capital peacekeepers alone Katniss
nearly makes it to the gates of
President Snow's Mansion but as the
capital's citizens desperately pass
their children forward through the crowd
bombs are dropped from a capital Airship
blasting catniss off her feet when she
opens her eyes she sees all the dead and
wounded civilians and the volunteer
Medics who have rushed in to treat them
just as Katniss spies Prim among the
Medics a second wave of bombs goes off
knocking Katniss out Katniss awakens to
the news that the rebels have won the
war snow has been taken into custody and
Prim is dead after being given a room in
the Mansion Katniss goes to the
greenhouse where snow is being kept and
demands an audience The Condemned snow
reveals to her that it is coin not him
who's responsible for the capital
bombing and her sister's death I must
concede it was a masterful move on
part horrified Katniss realizes that
Gail was likely the one who gave coin
the idea driving a permanent wedge
between them later during a meeting with
the leaders of the resistance several of
the remaining Victors are appalled when
coin suggests a new Hunger Games Capital
children will be the tributes this time
in order to satiate the people's need
for Revenge without giving in to massive
Bloodshed Katniss votes in favor of
these new games on the condition that
she be the one to execute snow but when
the time for this execution comes
Katniss kills coin instead she has
realized that allowing coin to remain in
charge will only lead to more of the
same oppressive conditions that got them
into this situation snow is subsequently
killed by the angry Spectators following
the deaths of president's coin and snow
Katniss is placed under arrest but is
then pardoned and allowed to return to
District 12 commander palor of District
8 is quickly elected pan M's new
president she acts to abolish The Hunger
Games demolish the Arenas and build
memorials to the many people who died it
is implied that henceforth panm will be
governed by its people who will select
their leader through free and fair
elections sometime during the years that
follow Katniss marries Peta and has two
children with him they both still suffer
from PTSD with Peta bearing the worst of
it due to the lingering effects of his
brainwashing he sometimes has to ask for
Katniss's help in determining what is
real though the scars that have been
left by the games and the capitals reign
of ter linger Katniss's decision to
start a family indicates her faith in
the future prior to the Games Katniss
swore to never have children believing
she could not bear to bring them into
such a harsh world now despite the
horror she has lived through her only
game is believing the world is worthy of
Hope gets a little tedious after all
these years
[Music]
but they're much worse games to
play